okay so far so good so we donate at
wayside called time this did your a
picture for why a cosine is called
criticized attached to the compliment
now I want to get to the bottom of these
other trig functions that we know that
because this is two out of six
so either side of truth line what's the
next basic way much better okay so
you've already got your eyes your next
unit circle on there but I'm only draw a
line on I'm only going to draw a part of
it so you'll have your hole in there but
I need as much space of mortal skin so
I'm only going to draw basically the
first quadrant okay now just like before
what I have your foot is and ideally if
you can actually pick the same spot on
the circumference put it on a point you
don't have to mark in is dumb it's
coordinates are fine now I want you to
help you see where 10 is what is
diagrams and therefore why it's called
10 first thing let's put the radius and
again still me a second
so you should have started off this
lesson by during Street inner circles
that is your second one okay now on here
I know where content types are but we
found some of it one extra piece of
information you need to know which I
know if the moment you're going to learn
in the quarter of the extension one of
course maybe you some of you might
remember if you looked at at the end of
you ten lucky but most people don't get
to it a circle property that's very very
useful is it if I want to keep your a
ten short oregon's changes if I were to
draw a tangent to the circle and if I
can likely control one now but if you've
got if you're doing colors I'm going to
say color in social so if I draw a
tangent off like that okay if you draw
your changeups or actually in attention
then you'll find that is it knuckle
exact right angles to that radius that
we sell them it is on both sides and
your website of sidewinder so me that is
right-angled is a nice proof of that or
we deter our sentiments different
geometry I'll show it to you then in
that tension is perpendicular to that
radius I can now work out all the stuff
in this triangle becomes like gaining
time right so in particular this side
that I've drawn in blue again I'm
interested in what day now don't forget
I have picked the same angle over there
like I had here so there's actually
entangled
speed up over here so when you come from
the perspective of this angle and you
relate these two sides together in a
winding sometimes you've got hypotenuse
opposite and adjacent which combinations
you have in this pen
this one Bachmann said this month Jensen
right
so by definition I could say Candida in
this on this feel great but this is
divided by one so can figure is just
this does that make sense
let me write it for you just don't like
this up because I'm going to write
either question masculine second ten
videos office it all into Jason yes you
see what I've done
well you don't need to write a provision
by one so that just me but that thing
you don't know is can be up for some
because something out and you should do
two on there right in okay bigger over
there now tangent again we're going to
come to this very important concept we
were looking to calculate the tangent
comes from the word to touch it just
touches the circle just touches by the
way we have another word in the English
language that comes from the same group
which also do in touching ten ten
tangible when something can be touched
and personally intended right so this
pageant is just touching each other
that's why we call this ratio sino to
college we call it ten because it's the
length of this tension measured from
whatever point on this because you want
down to the exact that is 10 and we call
a tan because it's all expectation now
I'm not quite done each one of the tree
and functions are basic points comes in
care that is a function and then there's
the compliment of that one right sorry
what's the continent of champion thought
we should towards the shorts of protein
which is short for her change it which
is short for from the compliment of the
changes okay now my question is where is
caught on this diet now I said that
exactly a lot of places that is you can
construct a whole bunch of training on
here but here's where I think is the
most helpful place
I'm going to add in some construction so
over here I'm going to remember I didn't
draw that on tangent I'm in fluorescent
okay up there now I want you to think
about that trailer that I've now formed
up here in the top left this angle here
is a corner what is that that has to be
the cop of the figure others because
look it's between the external APIs or
angle and total so that makes this guy
90 degrees minus fear deal rent don't
forget we already noticed the tangent
ready are at right angles there so this
is also a right angle
what does that make my angle right up
there in the corner this guy that's
beyond this is it that's better now
keeping by what's going on fearful in
business feeder okay what is this red
links which red ones here
well I can see this in a couple of
different ways if I then think about
chance like I can say I'm not see very
strong anymore I can say in this
triangle here can see that is well the
definition that we came back to its
opposite on adjacent right so what
divided by what opposite on adjacent
you're great like that well if you want
to know that unknown resting at the top
there what should you do you should take
reciprocals of both sides you can do
that it's an equation it's not an
inequality but must be marked okay so
you hit reciprocal on both sides this
becomes just the thing you're trying to
find out in question mark and this be
calm and do you learn it just like sign
with opposite here and closed we
opposite the compliment of theta DC look
we're Chaney's 10 is opposite CR and cut
is opposite the complement of business
are you see I should point out like a
servable
with other places copy
is in this library but I think that's
always obvious place that I can fear the
10 PR and cop it up there's both sides
of this tension this is the fight going
to X this is the type attached to the
common product